hello and welcome i'm james murphy and
today we're going to be testing to see
how fast is python's built-in sort
well i've already got the code here
let's just uncomment it you see
i make a list i shuffle it up and then i
time how long it takes to sort it and
print it out
so let's see how long it takes well
there you go 207 microseconds
end of the video right well no obviously
there are a ton of things wrong with the
way that i tried to profile this
for one i'm recording the video at the
same time that i ran the test
and that's definitely going to affect
the speed if i want to measure the
performance of sort in a more reliable
way better than this quick and dirty
implementation
then i'm going to have to put a little
bit more thought into it
so for starters i've listed out here
some of the common things that
affect the performance of a sort these
first four
obvious things the performance can also
depend on less obvious things like the
order that you
run the tests in this is a very common
trap that people fall into if you're not
familiar with performance testing
consider this case for example i have
two functions function and function two
and i wanna see which one is faster so
i write the most obvious thing i just
profile them one at a time i run it
see how much time it took and then i run
the second one and see how much time it
took
well let's do it so in this case we can
see
671 versus 417 so it looks like function
2 is better
right well just to be sure let's run it
again
okay this time it was about 500 versus
300 so the numbers were a little bit
different
but it still definitely looks like the
second one is better
okay so what are these two functions
well the first one i was just converting
a range
of 10 000 integers to a list and the
second function
i was oh well it's exactly the same
function
so you can see that it's not function
one or function two that's slower
it's whichever one ran first is the
slower one
and in addition to all these things of
course it matters what else is running
on your machine at the same time
and all kinds of wild things can affect
the performance that's why performance
testing
is actually a very very subtle and
tricky field
what i'm going to show you here today of
course is only going to be applicable
for my computer my operating system my
version of python
and everything else that's specific to
just my machine
but the source code is on the github
page so if you want to see how fast
your sort is then feel free to run the
code yourself
okay so let's get started so the first
thing that i'm going to define
is a sorting test case this specifies
everything that you need
to run a single test for a single size
one time then you can run the test
as many times as you want to get better
data about your test case
the size here is meant to represent the
size of the list
that you're going to be sorting the seed
allows me to ensure that i have a
reproducible test case every time
this data maker is another class that
we're defining essentially its job
is to take in the size and seed and give
you some data
so part of a test case is you need to
generate some data
and then sort it so the data maker tells
you how to generate the data
and then the sort keyword arguments tell
you
what arguments you pass to the sort
finally this field of times is where we
store the results of our
runs of the test so let's take a look at
this data maker class
well in actuality there's not much in
data maker it is an abstract base class
it's essentially defining an interface
all i'm saying is that anything that
claims to be a data maker
needs to have a make method it needs to
take in the size
and the seed and produce a list of data
that we're going to sort
the compatible keys and compatible sort
keyword arguments functions here
are not really important at this stage
they're essentially just saying for this
type of data maker
what kind of things can you call the
sort function with
so what is an example of a data maker
well the simplest thing is how about
random integers so you can see an
implementation of a data maker is very
simple
all i do is specify this make function i
use
the numpy seed function to see the numpy
random generator
and then i use numpy random to generate
random integers between
you know some low and high of the given
size and then i convert that to a list
so this would be your typical most
common sorting case you're just sorting
integers
for this data maker it's a sorted
uniform in maker
meaning i start by getting uniform ins
and then i sort them
so this is going to be useful for
testing how long does sort take on data
that's already sorted
and then you could have something like
nearly sorted which is i start out with
something sorted and then
make 10 random swaps in it does that
affect things i don't know
we'll find out the rest of these are
just slight variations on the same idea
with different types or different you
know extra parameters
so uniformly distributed floats between
zero and one
same thing as the previous but sorting
them what if i generate using a gaussian
distribution or normal distribution
instead of a uniform distribution
this maker looks at the case where there
aren't that many choices of what the
answer could be
so you could see my low here is 0 and
the high of 32 so there's only
33 choices of possible answer and then
these two just make random strings or
sorted random strings finally for data
makers
i've defined a class here two wins in a
string this is meant as a stand-in
in your code you have defined some
classes
and for whatever reason you don't want
them to be just you know a tuple or
something
it's a real class pretend that it has
extra methods and it does things
and it's only data members are x y and s
so how long does it take to sort a class
that has
a you know built in less than operator
then this maker just makes random int
random randomint and then random strings
and then plops them into the two instead
of string class and returns a list of
those
so this one is the same as the previous
one except
instead of storing x y and z in this
class two instead of string
we're going to store it just in a tuple
and now we're back down to the sorting
test case
so you can see now what this is we have
our size c data maker so this is going
to be something like our uniform
int maker which is going to tell us okay
given this size
and seed go ahead and make me some data
then what does the run do well it just
times how long does it take to sort
so it does the timing and then appends
the time to the end of the
times list the next function i want to
look at is this make all test cases
basically it takes in a list of sizes
seeds
and data makers that you want to test
and then it creates
all the test cases and then puts them in
a big list of test cases
once i have my big list of test cases i
pass it to this function
run tests and times which actually does
something very important
so in order to counteract the problem
that we saw at the beginning where the
order that we run the tests in
affects the answer to the you know
performance test
in order to counteract that we're
actually going to shuffle our tests
so we're going to shuffle them and then
run all of them and then shuffle them
and then run all of them and so on and
so forth
this many times once i run all my tests
then
i'm going to convert them to a pandas
data frame for easy processing and
plotting
and then i will make a plot out of it so
let's see how it's all put together in
main
first off we have this recompute results
if this is true
that means you want to actually run all
the tests
and once you run the test it's actually
going to save it to a file save the
results to a file
so that if you just want to show the
plot again and not rerun all the tests
again
you can just set this to false and then
rerun it this parameter just lets you
choose whether or not you also want to
show the reverse sorts in the same plot
then here are the important things so
what sizes are we going to be testing
well range 1024 so the number zero to
1023
and what seeds am i using well zero
through nine
and then finally trials is the number of
times that i'm going to run
every single test case so same seed same
size
i'm going to run every single one 20
times
then here i have my list of data makers
and you can see i just
make an instance of each of those maker
classes i'm just going to test
everything
so you can see if we want to recompute
the results then we
make all the test cases run them end
times convert them to a data frame
and then pickle them to a file if we
don't want to recompute things
then we hit this else and just read the
existing file
and then filter out the data makers that
we're not interested in
so of course i can't run this code
while i'm recording so i'm going to go
ahead and do that
offline and then show you the results
that i got which are then going to be
saved
into this file the first thing that i
notice is that there are definitely
clumps of twos
so you can see for each of these lines
there's essentially two colors and
that's because the reverse sort and the
forward sword are taking essentially the
same time
okay so let's comment out these and just
look at the ants
so the first thing that i notice is what
are these down at the very bottom
so if i click on these you can see that
these sorted ones are the ones down at
the bottom
so python is definitely doing something
that's a lot faster for already sorted
arrays
i also notice that the reverse sort is
always
slightly above the normal sort that kind
of makes sense because to do a reverse
sort
you just reverse sort and then reverse
or that's how python does it anyway
okay let's get rid of the sorted ones
and the reversed ones
so the difference between these three
curves is essentially due to the
distribution
so this pink one is the uniform
the blue one is the one that was uniform
but there were only a few choices so
the blue one had a lot of overlaps
and then the green one was nearly sorted
so it wasn't as fast as
the ones that were already sorted but it
does seem to be
quite a bit faster than the ones that
aren't sorted so here are the floats and
again we see that the reverse ones are
pretty similar to
the non-reversed ones so let me just
hide those
and again we see that the already sorted
one is the fastest one by a large margin
and then the difference between these
two is whether it was a uniformly
distributed float
or a normally distributed gaussian
distribution so
we can see that whether it's uniform or
normal makes essentially no difference
for
floats let's move on to strings once
again the
sorted ones are much faster and reverse
sorting a sorted collection of strings
is doing significantly worse than the
sorted version
but significantly better than just
random
however just for random strings reverse
sorting
is just about the same as normal sorting
all right let's finally go to two ins
and a string
and we see something very surprising for
this one well first let me note
unsurprisingly
sorting this struct took quite a bit
longer than
sorting just an integer but the
surprising thing is here
look at the difference between sorting a
class
versus sorting a tuple that contains the
same information as the class
the reverse sorting is essentially the
same as the forward sorting
now we just see the difference this blue
line
is trying to sort a list of elements
of a class and the green line is sorting
the same exact elements
but just stored in a tuple that's a huge
difference
yeah so this is like 1 10 the time scale
so that's an interesting find
all right let me just put the picture
back up where i'm not going to show any
of the reverse plots
and i'm not going to show any of the
sorted things just so we can get one
final glimpse
at the picture of how long it takes to
sort so this is kind of the final
picture that you can take away from this
process but i just want to reiterate
some of the lessons that we've
learned through exploring this data
so the final answer to the question how
fast is python's built in sort
is it depends it depends on how much
you're sorting
what type of data what the parameters of
the sort are
what's the distribution of the data and
all kinds of different
other things completely unrelated to the
data so there's
no real one answer of course the real
point of this video
is that if you want to measure
performance and you want a reliable
answer you need to test it yourself on
your own hardware
in a production setting where you're
going to be using it you need to control
as many of these different variables as
you can
and make them as realistic as possible
so sorry if the title was clickbait
as always thanks for watching don't
forget if you liked the video leave a
like and if you especially liked the
video consider subscribing
see you in the next one